all right joining me now is pulitzer
prize winning independent journalist
glenn greenwald whose work you can find
always on sub stack glenn
now i was watching this announcement
unfold today i i just could not help but
notice
that kamala harris and her online policy
task force
it just sounds like the old dhs
information board
but now it's run out of the white house
what are your thoughts tonight
it's really bizarre you know on the one
hand you can kind of mock it as the
triviality that it is she was supposed
to be integrated into foreign policy to
get her foreign policy bona fides she
was going to solve root cause problems
in central america and stem the tide of
immigration and now suddenly she's
basically like a glorified content
moderator for twitter to protect
washington post reporters who are going
on television weeping about mean tweets
they're getting but on the other hand
it's actually more menacing than that
and i do think it is part of this
very sustained and systemic attempt on
the part of the u.s government and the
democratic party to create regimes of
censorship and information control over
the internet the place that we now use
most of all to get our information and
our flow of information and to censor it
for their own interest in the name of
calling whatever information they
dislike hate speech or disinformation
and the fact that they have the entire
u.s security state assembled there
makes it clear that it is something more
than just kind of a joke or a gesture
yeah that was a sign had the president
there merrick garland
and all these other agency heads
including by the way the surgeon general
who popped up at today's press
conference as well watch
it can no longer be acceptable for a
technology company to put out a product
and walk away from the responsibility
for how it impacts users and communities
it can no longer be okay for social
media platforms to be fertile grounds
for hatred
accountability matters
glenn where is the accountability for
those individuals who push these
lockdowns
of kids that went on in some cases for
almost two years shut them out of
schools drove suicide drug abuse
despondency despair
that was called disinformation a couple
of years ago now it's called
truth
so who gets to decide all that
this is the the critical part where i
mean listening to that it that is
actually incredibly menacing incredibly
insidious to have the attorney general
essentially saying
directing private companies twitter
facebook google telling them you are not
allowed to
air this kind of information that we
regard as hateful or we regard as gain
that is not the government's role to be
arbitrating our political debates by
instructing private companies what they
can and can't do and this has always
been the most misunderstood and over
most overlooked component of this big
tech censorship which is you know
democrats always say if you complain
about you know bias censorship oh well
these are private companies they can do
what they want i never knew democrats
thought about private enterprise that
way that the government has no role to
restrict them but the reality is the
whole time the democrats have been
threatening big tech in exactly the way
you just heard if you don't censor in
accordance with what we want we are
going to impose regulatory and legal
reprisals on you this is coming from the
government and not really emanating from
big tech yeah whether it was the surgeon
general or the attorney general or the
head of dhs or some you know dippy woman
in charge of the disinformation board
it's still sending a a chilling message
and a message of intimidation to critics
of various government policies you
cannot get away from that and glenn
there was um
a pretty sparsely covered
house hearing that it took place a
couple of days ago and
uh a professor that the biden dhs
is giving over
like a half a million dollars to
he exchanged in this interesting
conversation with congressman dan bishop
watch
stochastic terrorism you describe it as
quote a form of incited terrorism
whereby a communicator has access to a
platform and big audience you also say
that with respect to the 2019 el paso
walmart mass shooting
of people of hispanic descent that
president trump was a stochastic
terrorist of that event right correct
among others yes
okay it all relates to data and
collecting data as to whether one
connects to the other and that's the
research i'm trying to conduct now
so glenn now the professoriate
uh is in on the game as well
yeah what they're doing is promulgating
theories that have been long used by
censors to justify
censorship over the internet so let's
imagine that you probably recall three
years ago somebody went to a softball
field where republican congressmen
congregate to play softball and shot as
many as they could almost killing steve
scalise it turned out he was a very
fanatical fan of the rachel maddow show
he loved bernie sanders you could use
that same theory we just heard to say oh
well they're insightful terrorists they
lead people to do violence or the person
who just got arrested outside brett
kavanaugh's house attempting to murder
him because he didn't like the way he
was going to vote on roe and gun control
and you can say who radicalized him
these are terrorists these are the worst
and most dangerous theories that have
long been debunked and discredited to
say any information that i want censored
it's not really speech it's terrorism
it's disinformation it's hate speech
it's all the same thing which is an
attempt to prevent us from having the
right of free speech the constitution
guarantees
glenn great to see you as always hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else